el papá y en particular la recuerden que
cuando él a su vez voz sumo pontífice
hizo cosas que nadie esperaba que
hicieron sumo pontífice aquí tenemos
otras el papa ha llegado a irak ningún
sumo pontífice había llegado a irak
cuando lo segundo intentó hacerlo pero
no pudo por diferentes motivos y
obviamente por la realidad que se vivía
en el lugar por lo tanto obviamente que
este viaje es un viaje histórico es un
viaje histórico no solamente porque es
el primer católico pontífice que llega a
la región sino también ya por lo que él
está diciendo él está buscando palabras
con sus palabras con su forma de ser con
su estilo tan ameno del papá francisco
está buscando buscar la paz él dice que
es un mensajero de la paz es un
mensajero de la solidaridad y ha tenido
la oportunidad de poder encontrarse ya
con grupos distintos en la primera parte
de ese punto obviamente con todo el
aparataje protocolar que corresponde a
la llegada de él porque hay que recordar
que como sumo pontífice cumple una
función pero también es
es gobernador de un lugar de acuerdo al
vaticano por lo tanto tuvo ese elemento
protocolar y posteriormente se juntó con
él
con diferentes grupos políticos de
acuerdo que están en el lugar en donde
se dio se dio él dijo hablo de economía
habló y habló de cooperación habló de
silenciar las armas y dijo además que
todos somos hijos del mismo dios que es
muy interesante ese porque es un llamado
que hace el papá permanentemente desde
el inicio de su pontificado
abraham la cuna de ahí las tres grandes
religiones monoteístas marcial le
preguntó cuál es la comunidad cristiana
que recibe en irak a la que el papá
francisco a visitar y por qué algunos
afirman que está al borde de la
extinción
bueno lo que pasa es que efectivamente
es una comunidad muy golpeada de una
comunidad que como decía muy bien la
nota el 2003 con la invasión
norteamericana y posteriormente con todo
el proceso que se vive el estado
islámico brutal de acuerdo que culmina
recién el 2017 tenemos un país diezmado
y los cristianos de irak
sufrieron y siguen sufriendo en algunos
sectores lamentablemente a través de la
persecución que se hizo sobre ellos
muchos de ellos salieron del país ahora
de casi un millón de personas que
cristianos que salieron en el último
censo debemos recordar que habla de más
menos un millón y medio de cristianos
hoy día se habla de doscientos cincuenta
mil por lo tanto muchos de ellos ya
salieron han vuelto al país y unos
cuarenta y tres mil pero es muy poco
efectivamente porque porque las
condiciones todavía por el mundo
cristiano no están dadas por lo tanto
tenemos web efectiva una iglesia que
está viviendo por reglamento es presente
una situación bastante compleja